Kriegsrecht das ist das Wichtigste Wort
der Stunde im Ukraine Krieg Putin hat
das Kriegsrecht verhängt in diesen vier
ukrainischen Gebieten die seine Truppen
in diesem Krieg besetzt haben tja und
darüber waren wir sprechen mit
Bildreporter Björn striezelbjörn also
erklär uns mal Kriegsrecht was bedeutet
das jetzt ganz konkret eben für diese
annektierten Region
also das ist natürlich hauptsächlich ein
propagandistischer Begriff den das
putin-regime da verwendet denn de facto
sind ja diese besetzten Gebiete oder
also die Regionen in diesem Gebieten die
unter Kontrolle der der russischen Armee
stehen ohnehin ihr ihnen ausgeliefert
sie haben dort ohnehin schon das was man
gemeinhin mit Kriegsrecht verbindet
nämlich so eine allgemeine Mobilmachung
immer wieder vollzogen haben immer
wieder Leute zwangsrekrutiert vor allem
junge Männer die sie dann dort an die
Front gezwungen haben das wird jetzt
vermutlich noch mal mehr geben vor allem
aber hat glaube ich die Ausrufung ein
propagandistischen Zweck nämlich
der russischen Bevölkerung die darauf
vorzubereiten dass dort schwere
Abwehrkämpfe gegen die ukrainischen
gegen die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
voran bevorstehen weil dort eben weil
dort eben die Ukraine eine offensive
auch wieder auf rasson vorbereiten weil
dort ja die Stimmung auch der der
russischen propagisten
TV-Shows bisher sehr schlecht weil auch
mal versucht darauf hinzuweisen dass das
schwere Abwehrkämpfe werden und insofern
ist die Ausrufung dieses Kriegsrechts
glaube ich auch vor allem
propagandistisches Mittel denn wir
müssen auch über Frank-Walter Steinmeier
sprechen den Bundespräsidenten da gab es
ja schon langes Hin und Her fliegt dann
mal nach Kiew warum war er so lange
nicht da in der Ukraine während andere
Staats- und Regierungschefs das gemacht
haben dann das Gezerre der eine war
beleidigt der andere wurde ausgeladen
und so weiter und so fort jetzt gab es
den Termin für diesen Ukraine für diesen
Kiew besuchen jetzt hat Steinmeier den
ganz kurzfristig wieder abgesagt aus
Sicherheitsgründen sagt der das
Verstauen ein bisschen ist ja klar dass
das ein Kriegsgebiet ist hat sich die
Lage so verschärft in der Ukraine dass
das diese so kurzfristigen ein bisschen
unglückliche Absage von Steinmeier
erklärt
also es gibt natürlich andere Politiker
die hingeist sind insofern
kann man da kann man da jetzt nicht
sagen dass ich die Lage so sehr
verschärft hat dass es da das ist das
unmöglich mache machen würde für jeden
Spitzenpolitiker allerdings wenn er
seinen Sicherheits Sicherheitsteam zu
einer anderen Einschätzung gekommen ist
dann
ja muss man das so respektieren ich
glaube die politische Ironie er darin
das Frank-Walter Steinmeier als
Außenminister genau diese beiden Regie
mit die dort gerade in Kiew für für tot
und Terror sorgen also Russland
natürlich zu förderst aber eben auch
Iran weil Russland hat dort ja iranische
Drohnen eingesetzt in den letzten Tagen
das eben diese beiden Regime Iran und
Russland von Frank-Walter Steinmeier als
Außenminister massiv unterstützt wurden
er hat immer wieder sich stark gemacht
für den Atom die wir mit dem mit dem
mullerregime er hat dort den Säufern und
holocaustleugnen die Hände geschüttelt
er hat Wladimir Putin ermutigt während
dieser Aleppo gewittert werden russische
Kampfjets durch Krankenhäuser zerstört
haben hat er ihm zugesprochen ja man
könnte das ja danach gemeinsam also
Deutschland gemeinsam mit Russland das
wieder aufbauen insofern ist es halt
unten eine gewisse liegt daran schon
eine gewisse politische Ironie das
ausgerechnet Frank Walter Steinmeier nun
ähm ja sich nicht nach Kiew traut wo
eben diese beiden Regime den er so lange
zur Seite gestanden als auch besser die
dort möglicherweise auch seine
Sicherheit bedrohen können
ja danke schön für diese ganze aktuellen
Informationen aus der Ukraine
[Musik]